hey youtubers is charlie james gunn just
tease guardians of the galaxy to coming
to comic-con and some things are going
to be showing off they're basically
showing footage off in the movie so i'm
going to play this clip here then I'm
going to break down what they're
probably going to be bringing all right
ahhh we are here live from the set of
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 and I
there's a guy who I've been around for
about four years now three and a half
years become a close friend and we've
been through a long long journey
together and I am wrapping mr. Chris
Pratt from the set of guardians of the
galaxy value anyway thank you guys so
much i appreciate it i was gonna hit we
also want to let everybody on facebook
know that we have an announcement we
guardians of the galaxy valium to are
coming to san diego comic-con this year
we are gonna be there I'm going to be
there Chris Pratt is gonna be there a
bunch of the gang is gonna be there and
we're gonna show you guys something uh
something pretty cool James's movie yes
see you Carla ba so he's basically
rapping Chris Pratt on the movie here
they're pretty much done shooting
principal photography they said they
have a couple shots left but to have all
kinds of footage to pick from when they
bring it to comic-con so if you weren't
at comic-con 2013 that was when they
teased the first guardians movie they'd
only been shooting the movie for about
two weeks so they didn't have a whole
lot of footage the only part of that
teaser that made it into the final cut
of the movie like the stuff that we
actually saw in theaters was when Peter
quill was doing the middle finger when
they were in that lineup in the Nova
cords like what a bunch of a-holes he
was really just a montage introducing
all the Guardians characters because
you'd never really seen this version of
them on screen before so it was a way
for Marvel to show you how cool the
movie looked how Star Wars steampunky it
looked and how funny it was going to be
just a really quick teaser saying hey
this is kind of what the movies gonna
look like this is kind of what its gonna
feel like so that's probably what
they're going to bring to the second
movie but because we know these
characters they'll probably a couple
funny riffs from jokes from the first
movie like a howard the
collector type joke in addition to
teasing the new Guardian so mantis is
the new Guardian that's going to be
flying on the Milano James Gunn's been
teasing her from behind the scenes if
you didn't read the guardians of the
galaxy comic book there have been a
number of different versions of the team
she was on the team during the
annihilation conquest storyline that was
the story of how the Guardians came
together it was like an older version of
the team in the comics than that but the
elements from the first film were
largely inspired by that annihilation
conquest storyline even though the story
of it was dramatically different but
we've also been seeing teasers about the
villain she might be kismet but that's
not confirmed I don't know if they're
going to show the villain off in the
comic con teaser because usually the
comic con footage is meant to be a
little more funny they might include it
but like I'm not expecting to see
Sylvester Stallone or even kurt russell
it'd be amazing if they were in the
comic con teaser so let me know in the
comments below what do you guys think
they're going to include I think grood
is a big question mark to because we had
dancing baby Groot at the end of the
last movie obviously we all know that
Groot regrows himself so group will be
back to normal size by the end of the
movie but because they haven't really
explained how group works fully in the
movie universe we'll probably see that
play out over the first act of the film
at least like you'll see the film follow
up with Groot and he won't be fully
grown yet but in the comics he can
actually regrow himself pretty fast it
doesn't take that long you just take
like a small piece of bio matter from
him like a twig or something planted in
soil and water and boom he just regrows
himself like a tree would but I would be
very surprised if he's back to normal at
the beginning of the movie I just I
don't think that's going to be a thing
it feels like one of those things that
James Gunn would have some fun with side
note this is actually pretty interesting
a lot of the merchandising not the
marketing but the merchandising for
guardians of the galaxy two is based
around groots character I think that's
just because he was so popular when the
first movie came out they want to
capitalize on that but think about what
that means for his character in the
movie so even though there's going to be
a whole bunch of different things
happening we're going to learn Who Peter
quills father is there'll be another big
antagonist that's not Thanos they'll
follow up on Thanos but he's not going
to be the main antagonist they'll have
some giant Groot story that'll be
totally awesome i'll have another crazy
we are Groot moment something really
cool let me know in the comments that
what do you think that's going to be
like why do you think that Groot is a
much bigger deal than any of the other
characters for their merchandising
really I think it's like a little kid
toy cells thing
where people adults little kids everyone
unanimously loves Groot so they're like
okay great we'll just we'll go with him
because everyone likes him more than the
other characters but I haven't
completely finalized my comic con plans
so whatever ends up happening no worries
I'll totally do video for whatever
footage marple ends up bringing they'll
definitely be footage for guardians of
the galaxy maybe dr. strange but this is
coming out so close we'll probably
already have a bunch of footage for that
so we'll be quiet as many surprises I'm
expecting a few surprises from Marvel so
whatever ends up happening don't worry I
will totally do videos for it and for
those of you that are going to VidCon
next week i will be at VidCon it's not
this weekend but it's the weekend after
that so I will be there all weekend so
be sure to say hi if you guys are there
my next video will be spider-man because
they just confirmed that Michael Keaton
is playing the vulture he'll be the main
villain there's a couple other
characters that they've cast so I'll
explain everything whenever I post that
so why you guys wait for my next video
to post you can click here it's all
about Superman coming to Supergirl like
they actually cast the actor and you can
click here sooner all about the
guardians of the galaxy villain in Peter
quills father thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you